del tablero político al proceso judicial
tres eurodiputados independentistas
catalanes perdieron su inmunidad
parlamentaria tras el voto del
parlamento europeo alrededor de 400 de
705 políticos mayoritariamente de los
bloques populares socialistas y
liberales votaron a favor de que se
pueda extraditar al expresidente carles
puigdemont así como a toni comín y clara
punta ti sin embargo los datos muestran
fisuras en el parlamento europeo ya que
los verdes y la izquierda votaron en
contra de levantar el veto nosotros
presentaremos una demanda pero por otro
lado presentaremos una demanda en contra
de la decisión del parlamento europeo en
el tribunal europeo de justicia que es
el único que puede reparar el severo
daño que se le ha hecho a la democracia
europea al quitar la inmunidad a tres
miembros del parlamento por motivos
políticos
en 2019 tras las elecciones al
parlamento europeo se les negó a
acreditarse como eurodiputados hasta que
más tarde el tribunal superior de
justicia europeo fallo que tenían
derecho a recoger
su acta parlamentaria y disfrutar de la
inmunidad ante esa decisión el tribunal
supremo español pidió un suplicatorio en
el parlamento del que se ha conocido
este martes el resultado de no prosperar
el recurso legal el futuro de puig de
mont y los otros parlamentarios
dependerá de la extradición mediante una
orden judicial europea que ya ha sido
denegada anteriormente sin embargo desde
el gobierno español celebraron la
decisión y es que los problemas de
cataluña se resuelven en españa- no se
resuelven en europa el tribunal supremo
español reclama cargos de sedición y
malversación contra los políticos
catalanes en octubre de 2017 cataluña
celebra un referendo de
autodeterminación no reconocido y
posteriormente el govern de carles
puigdemont hizo una falsa declaración
unilateral de independencia